hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain a German post-apocalyptic
Thriller film called hell spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
it is the year 2075 temperatures
worldwide have increased by 10 degrees
causing the collapse of civilization the
sun is so hot that going outside during
daylight hours is dangerous crops have
been destroyed and failed little water
or food is available and social order is
broken the few survivors who have been
adapting to this hellish world must
Shield their skin with excess clothing
gloves smocks and anything they can
potentially get their hands on at the
start of the movie a young woman named
Marie her younger sister Leone and her
boyfriend Philip are traveling through
the dry Wasteland the only thing that
protects them from the deadly sun is an
old Volvo Wagon which is taped up with
metal mesh and newspapers on the Windows
only a narrow strip is left open for the
driver to see although the world has
become mostly uninhabitable it is
rumored that the mountains are still
green and halash with abundant food
supplies for everyone this is where the
trio is heading their usual routine
consists of Scavenging through wrecked
cars and gas stations in hopes of
finding extra gas water or even food the
condition is so severe that they even
raid toilets to quench their thirst all
this while they have to be alert of
hostile survivors as one wrong move
could cost them their lives one day the
trio comes across a ruined gas station
and quickly splits up Philip being the
leader and protector of the group tries
to obtain gasoline from the station's
underground tanks and abandoned vehicles
while the women scavenge for supplies in
the buildings after a bit of looking
around the Two Sisters managed to drain
some water from the bathroom water pipes
unfortunately while they are busy with
their work a hooded mystery man steals
food and water from their car Marie
quickly notices this and screams for
Philip who is still trying to retrieve
gas from the underground tank soon the
two go after the hooded man only to find
that their supplies are gone from the
car Philip gets angry shouting that he
is always the one having to keep an eye
on them why is it always me who must
fill up the tank shortly after as Maria
is looking for the man she realizes that
Leone is gone scared she screams her
sister's name but there is no response
she then fearfully goes inside the
station and looks for Leone when she
turns around she finds that the hooded
man has her sister as a hostage he
finally speaks and introduces himself as
Tom then he tells Marie to behave and
drop her weapon the latter complies but
suddenly Philip arrives at the scene and
ambushes the man they tussle for a while
and land Some solid punches on one
another but in the end Phillip subdues
his opponent and the two agree to a
truce of sorts in the next scene Tom
reveals he is a local mechanic and that
he has a decent amount of gas with him
he also warns Philip that it is
impossible to travel for a long distance
in the Volvo as its engine is not made
for extremely hot temperatures however
he knows away to make it more
long-lasting in exchange he just wants a
can of food and some water Philip thinks
about it for a while and eventually
agrees but as they are about to leave
Tom again starts talking about the
engine and how it may falter at any
moment so Philip who does not want to
take any chances decides to bring the
stranger along with them the girls are
skeptical about the idea but Philip
persuades them by saying two men are
better than one after a while the group
finally starts their Journey they drive
along through the desolate roads and
slowly head towards the mountains but on
their way they are suddenly stopped by a
huge metal structure that is blocking
the road the men get out and try to move
it but it just won't budge fortunately
with the help of their car they managed
to steer the structure clear off the
road this gives the group a moment of
Happiness which they celebrate with some
cheers just then they notice a wrecked
car a few meters down the hill the men
assume that it just crashed so they head
down to scavenge for supplies after
looking around for a while they discover
that the car belonged to a French couple
they also find some leftover food water
and gas through his walkie-talkie Philip
instructs Marie to bring down some
bottles and canisters however she
insists he come by himself and retrieve
whatever he wants Marie simply doesn't
want to leave her sister alone Leone
hears the conversation and realizes that
they see her as a burden so she tells
Marie to go without her while she locks
herself inside the car Maria is still
skeptical but when Philip keeps calling
her she departs after reaching them she
along with the Men start trying out a
French perfume they found inside the car
right then the group hears Leone screams
and they realize the blocked Road was a
trap they hastily climb up the hill but
Marie trips off and Falls unconscious on
the ground when she wakes up she finds
herself alone in the woods coming back
to her senses Marie moves forward and
joins Tom on the way he explains that it
was too late when he and Philip got to
the car Leone was already abducted by a
group of survivors who thrive on
cannibalism in this newfound hellish
world when the duo nights with Philip in
the woods Marie convinces them to try to
free Leone however Philip doesn't want
to risk their lives so he wants to
continue their Journey to the mountains
Leone wanted to fend for herself serves
her right if she gets eaten by other
humans while the two are having an
argument over this Tom spots smoke in
the distance and encourages the group to
investigate wasting no time the trio
follows the smoke and realizes that it
is coming from a large fire at a
survivor's encampment where Leone and
other hostages are kept chained up the
group is horrified by what they see but
Tom comes up with a plan he asks Marie
and Philip to help him in creating a
diversion the plan is to throw a Molotov
cocktail so that Marie can take their
stolen car back while he and Philip
rescues Leone Marie immediately agrees
and sets off to their car parked on the
road she begins to warm up the engine
when one of the abductors feels
something is wrong he comes forward to
check but at the same time Tom throws
the molotov cocktail this sends all the
bad guys into a state of panic and
taking advantage of the opportunity
Marie starts the car and waits for the
two men to arrive however Philip decides
to go against the plan as he is too
scared to risk his life so instead of
joining Tom he gets into the car with
Marie and urges her to drive away in a
hurry Marie drives off but she keeps
asking for her sister and Tom Philip
lies that he couldn't break Leone's
chains so he had to leave without her
during their escape Phillips foot is
badly injured in a fight with one of the
abductors he encourages Marie to
consider Leone a lost cause but she is
adamant on rescuing her once they reach
a safe spot Marie realizes Philip didn't
even try to save her sister she then
decides to leave alone to search for
Leone after a while she comes across a
tunnel where she finds Leone's bag this
means that the Scavengers are residing
nearby just then a limping Shadow
appears in the background and it is
Philip who apologizes for going against
the plan earlier he promises that they
will look for leonie and Tom together
however Philip is too injured to walk so
Marie insists he stay in the tunnel
until she can get help having no other
choice he obliges following this Marie
Ventures out into the scorching Sun
looking for traces of her sister and the
scavenger Tom due to the overwhelming
heat she takes refuge in a nearby ruined
Church she then falls asleep on the
floor and a few hours later an old woman
named Elizabeth awakens her expectedly
Maria is terrified of the stranger but
Elizabeth calms her down and offers her
some water the two then start chatting
and Marie opens up about her situation
she explains how her sister and friend
have been abducted by some Savages so
she is looking for them Elizabeth
reveals that she has never heard about
those Savages but nonetheless she
promises to help but first she incest
Marie come to her farm and take some
rest the latter immediately Falls victim
to the kind words of Elizabeth and
agrees to come with her she also reveals
Philip's location and pleads for help
later we see Elizabeth's Barn as she
explains to Marie that all of her
livestock have been destroyed due to the
heat there is little food and their
family sustains themselves with the help
of a nearby Pond where they have tamed
some fish initially the woman seems
friendly and shows around the house she
then takes Marie to a room where she can
sleep for the day tired Marie quickly
falls asleep only to awaken and find
herself locked in the room peering out
through a small hole she sees a young
boy playing sword fight with his friend
she leans in closer to see what looks
like abducted captives being led about
Marie also sees an injured Philip being
brought into the barn this is when she
realizes that Elizabeth and her family
are the actual abductors who have been
setting Road traps and ambushing
travelers suddenly Elizabeth opens the
locked door and barges in she reveals
that Philip will be used for his meat as
they have no other options now he'll
fill up their stomachs that's for sure
as for Marie and her sister Leone they
will be spared because of their youth
and B D however they will be forced to
marry Elizabeth's Sons helpless Marie
tries to fight back but to no avail
Elizabeth then leaves a blue dress on
the table and asks her to wear it during
dinner before locking the door she also
explains the consequences if someone is
caught while trying to escape they will
be quickly executed and fed to her
family members after she leaves Marie
looks around the room searching for an
escape door suddenly the door opens once
again and it's Leone the sisters finally
reunite and embrace each other with
tears in her eyes Marie promises that
she will get them out the Two Sisters
then begin making a rope out of their
clothes so that they can jump out of the
window and Escape unfortunately there is
a knock at the door once again and Marie
hurdly instructs her sister to pretend
to be asleep Elizabeth's son Misha opens
the door and mentions that he is here to
Aid Leone's wounds but when he gets too
close to the window where the sisters
have planned their escape Marie suddenly
kisses him when he gets distracted she
strikes him with a large piece of wood
injured and angry Misha begins to choke
her but in the nick of time Leone
smashes a heavy object on him knocking
him out after that the two sisters
hurriedly prepare to escape through the
window Marie urges Leone to jump through
the window first and go to the woods to
hide the little sister obliges and after
she is gone Marie hears someone at the
door she decides to stay back and play
it cool she then changes her clothes
into the blue dress that Elizabeth left
for her shortly after Marie goes
downstairs and soon stumbles upon
Elizabeth who is busy preparing dinner
the woman seems happy as it seems that
Maria is adapting to the place when
asked about Misha she tells Elizabeth
that he is still cleaning up Leone's
wounds she is then guided to the kitchen
where Elizabeth's whole cannibal family
sits down for dinner they chant some
creepy prayers thank you cannibal jabus
and then get ready to eat some human
meat Marie is also served a plate and
everyone is waiting for her to begin
scared she tries to escape from the
family but Misha who has regained his
Consciousness stops her by the door in
the next scene Marie is bound and put in
the slaughterhouse there she sees Philip
who is also tied across the room soon
after Misha arrives and executes Philip
ready to turn his corpse into human food
when the murderous Misha leaves the
slaughterhouse Marie manages to grab a
knife from Phillips clothes and untie
herself she then escapes and opens a
locked door in the barn where she finds
many captives including Tom wasting no
time all of them start fleeing with the
cannibal family in Pursuit Tom fights
with and dispatches several of the
abductors when Maria is nearly hit by
one of them Tom saves her by attacking
the abductor from behind while the men
wrestle for their lives Marie manages to
escape and run through the woods in
search of her sister after a while she
does find Leone but the latter is being
bound by Elizabeth and one of her sons
the old woman then confronts Marie
saying that she thought Marie was
different now they want to take Leone
with them so that she can marry one of
Elizabeth's sons and raise a family
Marie plays it cool and waits for an
opening and when the woman comes close
she takes her chance and stabs her with
the knife from earlier while the sun
Mourns his mother Elizabeth Marie
releases Leone and escapes the Two
Sisters then join Tom and flee to the
mountains where they find drips of water
and cool places up in the sky they also
see birds the trio then locks Over The
Ridge at the Garden of hills in Hope of
a better fate there however they see
nothing but even more wrecked and
parched wastelands down in the valley
what uh what did they expect subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching